In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sina Xarion from May 12th, on which we commemorate our Holy Father
Epiphanyus of Cyprus, on the 12th of the month we celebrate the memory of our Holy
Father Epiphanyus, Bishop of Salamina on Cyprus.
Our Holy Father Epiphanyus was born in 315, or 308, into a modest Jewish family from
the village of Besindok near Eleopheropolis in Palestine.
On the death of his father, he was adopted by Trifon, a doctor of law, who planned to
give him his daughter in marriage.
Possessed of a great zeal for learning from his youth, Epiphanyus studied the Holy Scriptures
and the institutions of Jewish life and faith at his side, and learned five languages,
Greek, Latin, Hebrew, Syriac, and Coptic, a very rare achievement at that time.
On Trifon's death, he inherited all his fortune.
One day while he was visiting his estate on horseback, he passed by a Christian monk
named Lucien, who, having met a poor man and having no money himself, took off his garment
and gave it to the man, whereupon a garment of radiant whiteness descended from heaven
to cover him.
This sign confirmed the admiration Epiphanyus had felt for the Christians since his childhood,
when he had been miraculously saved by a Christian from his bolting horse.
Starting at Lucien's feet, he begged him to baptize him and to accept him into the
angelic order.
Baptized together with his sister by the bishop of the city, he gave away all his wealth
and became a disciple of Saint Heladion, who strict asceticism he followed for the rest
of his life.
The mysteries and figures of the Old Testament, finding their full meaning in the light of
Christ, he gave himself with renewed order to study, and eager to learn about the lives
of the monks of Egypt, undertook a long journey in Egypt that land of predilection for the
ascetic life.
He also learned of the doctrines professed by the numerous and varied sects and heretical
groups abounding there, thus gathering together the elements of his monumental treatise against
all heresies, which he wrote in the twilight of his life.
Having only narrowly escaped from the machinations of the Manequians, he returned to Palestine
four years later and founded a monastery near his village, which he directed with great wisdom
for thirty years.
It is said that he made water flow from parched land, and that the monks' cells were
built by the Bedouins who had witnessed his miracles.
By the invocation of the name of Christ and thanks to the gift of prescience, Epiphanios
cast out the demons that tormented the people of the village and some of his monks.
He also delivered the region from a fearsome man-eating lion and was known for his abundant
almsgiving.
It was above all by his gifts of teaching and interpreting the scriptures that he
shone as a star over the whole church.
Realising the danger that Greek philosophy represented for the church as a source of multiple
heresies, he devoted himself throughout his whole life to the battle in defense of the
true faith.
It is said that a famous philosopher came from Odessa to saint Epiphanios' monastery
to discuss the holy scriptures with him.
They debated for a long time about the mysteries of creation.
Epiphanios holding the holy Bible in his hand and the philosopher the writings of Hesseod.
Although the light of the truth was clearly manifest, the philosopher remained obter it.
Yet when he saw Epiphanios heal someone possessed by a demon through the invocation of the name
of Christ, he renounced worldly wisdom and asked to be baptized.
He was later ordained priest and became the saint's successor at the head of the monastery.
After leaving his monastery to flee from human glory, Epiphanios went to Cyprus, where he
had the great joy of finding Saint Ilarion once more.
Through the pressure placed on him by Saint Ilarion, Epiphanios accepted consecration as Bishop
of Constantia Salamina in 376.
He saw in this elevation no occasion of vanglory but rather as a means of escaping from the intrigues
of the semi-Aryan heretics who were strongly influential in Palestine.
For 26 years he showed an exemplary zeal in the governing of his diocese and in the strengthening
of the Orthodox faith, both in Cyprus and in the rest of the world.
Numerous miracles strikingly confirmed his pastoral virtues and his paternal love for his flock.
His generosity and interventions in support of those who were victims of injustice drew the hate
of some of his clergy upon him, led by Deacon Carinas, who accused him of squandering the church's
money. In spite of all the attempts of the latter to bring the Saint into disrepute,
Epiphanios always showed him the same benevolence. Carinas finally being chastised by God and coming
to a miserable end. It is said that when the Saints celebrated the divine liturgy,
he would see the Holy Spirit descending on the gifts to sanctify them. One day he was deprived
of this vision because of the unworthiness of one of his consultants. After having taken him aside,
Saint Epiphanios implored God with tears and would not continue the celebration until the divine
glory showed itself once more. Very attentive to the moral integrity of his clergy,
the Holy Prelate wanted his clerics by their virtues to be worthy adornments of the bride of Christ.
He therefore transformed his episcopal palace into a monastery where he lived the common life
with more than seventy of his clergy. In 382, leaving the government of his diocese to St.
Philan of Carpasia, Epiphanios travelled to Rome in the company of St. Jerome and Paulinas of Antioch,
with the aim of resolving the Antiochian schism in favour of the latter. They stayed in St.
Paul's house and the Saint's biographer recounts that he worked striking miracles there and healed
the sister of the co-emperors, Arcadius and Onorios. Returning to Cyprus at the time of a terrible famine,
he gave the people the wheat he had bought from those who had a monopoly with gold acquired after
receiving a vision. In his zeal to cast out all trace of Hellenism from Christian theology,
St. Epiphanios concentrated his efforts particularly against the doctrines of origin, at the time very
much in favour among the monks of Palestine. In 393, preaching in Jerusalem on the feast of the
dedication of the Church of the Resurrection, he proclaimed that origin was the father of Aryanism
and of every heresy. The same evening, Patriarch John, whom Epiphanios reproached for his sympathy with
the originists, replied by attacking the anthropomorphists, the adversaries of the allegorical exegesis
of Scripture held in high esteem by the great Alexandrian doctor. The quarrel grew bitter and became
inflamed, especially when St. Jerome took Epiphanios' side against Patriarch John and his own
former friend, Rufinus of Aquileia. Leaving the tormented city, Epiphanios spent some time in his
monastery in Alethedopolis, then returned to his diocese. Without, however, abandoning the struggle in
which his ardent character and his simplicity had led him to take up an extreme position.
The torch of the anti-originist struggle then passed to Thelphilos, Archbishop of Alexandria
in the year 401. He, having once been a disciple of origin, had become his ferocious and implacable
enemy through his desire to pour out his bitterness against four brothers of noble birth,
known as the long brothers because of their height, who preferring Hissequia to ecclesiastical
honors had left his clergy without his authorization to become monks in nitria.
Pursued by the Archbishop, they took refuge in Constantinople in the hope of gaining support for
their cause from St. John Chrysostom. Using the occasion to accuse Chrysostom of whom he was
jealous of being the protector of the originist heresy, Thelphilos addressed himself to Epiphanios.
Il informed about the situation and of Thelphilos' real motives, the elderly bishop believing himself
to be engaged in the defense of orthodoxy went to Constantinople after having condemned
originism in a synod of the bishops of Cyprus. Welcomeed with reverence by Chrysostom,
he refused all his proffered marks of honor and went to stay in a private house.
He then proceeded to ordain a deacon in one of the local monasteries. St. Chrysostom
let him know that he was extremely grieved to learn that his brother in the Episcopate had thus
acted in contravention of the Holy Canons and that he had stirred up the people against their
pastor without reason. St. Epiphanios then decided to return home to cease being a source of discord,
and he left the capital shortly before the unholy synod of the oak, which deposed St. John Chrysostom
in the year 403. He gave his soul into God's hands during the sea crossing
in the 12th of May, in the year 403. After having exhorted his disciples to preserve the purity
of the true faith and to keep themselves from the snares of riches and of calumny,
when the ship arrived in Salamina an immense crowd bearing candles in their hands welcomed
its shepherd and accompanied him with tears to the church. Where for seven days a great part of
the population of Cyprus came to venerate his body. The veneration of St. Epiphanios spread rapidly
and his tomb still remains one of the most devoutly observed pilgrimage places on the island of which
he is the holy patron along with St. Barnabas. Through the prayers of our holy fathers,
O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.